hello and welcome to frequently asked
questions with the Forgan this video
serves to answer the most common
questions I get asked in regards to my
voice ever work on this channel I will
address these questions now number one
what software or hardware do you use the
software I use to edit audio is called
Adobe Audition cs6 and the microphone I
use to record is a samson c01u USB
studio condenser number two can I
collaborate with you I would love to
collaborate with you I just need to know
what you sound like and what project you
would like to collaborate with me on I
simply need to know your audio quality
will be the same as mine otherwise the
audio will sound all weird hahahaha it's
very humorous number three what is your
natural accent my accent is Northern
Irish this is what it sounds like
enjoy number four I want to request an
SCP but don't have Facebook what am I
going to do well you can use my Twitter
or my email the links will be in the
description and the video outro but the
next one is not a question but I believe
it deserves an honorable mention you
sound like Stephen Merchant
or Wheatley from the video game series
portal no I don't thank you very much
for listening and I look forward to
seeing you again next time on frequently
asked questions with the Volgin
goodbye